[Música]
en los últimos meses se ha vuelto cada
vez más habitual en nuestras
conversaciones el concepto de
Inteligencia artificial lo que hace unas
décadas era casi ciencia ficción se ha
vuelto algo cotidiano especialmente
desde la apertura al público de la
herramienta chat gpt creado por la
empresa openiye la polémica ha llegado
por la falta de regulación especialmente
sobre los datos de los usuarios lo que
ha llevado a prohibir el uso del chat
gpt en Italia por ejemplo pero también
por las incertidumbres que plantea
respecto a su desarrollo a que este
pueda escaparse del control de los
investigadores y Por ende evaluar los
riesgos potenciales para la sociedad
para analizar todos estos puntos
Hablamos ahora con Borja Azuara Varela
abogado experto en derecho estrategia y
comunicación digital asuntos públicos y
regulatorios Borja Buenos días les
saludo desde los estudios de France 24
aquí en Bogotá más de mil investigadores
e inversores en esta tecnología como
elon musk pidieron un cese de seis meses
en el desarrollo de chat gpt Más allá de
la versión 4.0 actual el comunicado
parecía tener un tono casi apocalíptico
realmente es preocupante el camino que
está llevando la Inteligencia artificial
Bueno yo creo que sí y no es decir la
tecnología Nunca es preocupante lo que
es preocupante es los malos usos de la
tecnología pero a veces
preocupados lógicamente por esos malos
usos nos olvidamos de los buenos usos y
tenemos muy próximos buenos usos Como
por ejemplo la investigación para
obtener la vacuna contra el covid o la
lucha contra el cáncer es decir la
Inteligencia artificial salvavidas
también lo que tenemos que estar
vigilantes por tanto no es por el uso el
desarrollo de la Inteligencia artificial
sino por la maldad humana porque yo no
tengo miedo a la máquina yo tengo miedo
a los seres humanos que utilizan mal las
máquinas con lo cual lo que tiene la
tecnología es que una vez inventada ya
no se puede desinventar con lo cual
decir Bueno hay que pararlo pues es un
poco difícil porque una vez que está
inventado no se va a parar lo que hay
que estar es vigilante para que no se
haga malos de la Inteligencia artificial
y por ejemplo nos podría dar el ejemplo
del que podría ser un mal uso de la
Inteligencia artificial Sí por supuesto
no hace falta que vayamos a cuestiones
apocalípticas ni de guerras que también
podrían guiar misiles o tomar decisiones
en armas de guerra no sino Simplemente
hay tres ámbitos de cotidianos en el que
en los que Perdón Pues todavía no está
muy clara La regulación las
consecuencias jurídicas uno ya lo ha
mencionado es el de protección de datos
personales porque lo que ha dicho Italia
es que no cumple la empresa Open ahí con
el reglamento general de protección de
datos europeo que le obliga cuando
presta estos servicios a dar una serie
de información a los usuarios sobre el
tratamiento que se hace de esos datos
personales que finalidad tiene para que
se recaban si se acceden a terceros
etcétera eso es un primer ámbito pero es
que al lado de la protección de datos
personales por ejemplo está la propiedad
intelectual porque estas inteligencias
artificiales generativas se alimentan se
entrenan con obras de autores que están
sujetos a copyright a derechos de
propiedad intelectual con lo cual estos
autores Están preocupados diciendo Oiga
están utilizándose mis obras sin recibir
ninguna compensación para luego generar
nuevas obras y esos derechos de quién
son de las nuevas obras O sea que el
ámbito de la propiedad intelectual
también es otro ámbito preocupante Pero
hay uno tercero que para mí es el más
preocupante que es el de la libertad de
expresión y el de la libertad de
información porque con Inteligencia
artificial creativa o generativa se
pueden crear por ejemplo Pues muchas
fake news porque no dice que de qué
Fuentes
se nutre no para
publicar un artículo por ejemplo con lo
cual yo creo que la fiabilidad del
conocimiento la fiabilidad de la
información creo que además en un año
electoral por ejemplo como tenemos en
España es muy peligroso fiarse de
noticias generadas por Inteligencia
artificial que no sabemos como hacen los
periodistas no que contrastan las
fuentes pues no sabemos de qué Fuentes
ha bebido para generar esa noticia claro
y también imágenes no que hemos visto
como la del papa con un abrigo que no
estaba llevando en realidad o la de
Donald Trump siendo detenido no imágenes
que fueron creadas también con
Inteligencia artificial pero una de las
preocupaciones que digamos corre entre
la sociedad es el de pensar que los
humanos vamos a llegar a ser
completamente sustituidos por ejemplo en
nuestros puestos de trabajo qué tan
cerca está esta realidad Bueno yo creo
que hay tareas que se iban a ser
sustituidas y afortunadamente Porque
todo lo que se pueda automatizar yo creo
que hay que automatizarlo no no son
trabajos especialmente
satisfactorios para nadie estar
apretando tuercas y da lo mismo la
metáfora en cualquier trabajo creo que
el ser humano se va a ir reservando para
los trabajos más creativos y para
entrenar y supervisar los trabajos que
hagan las inteligencias artificiales
porque una cosa es la Inteligencia
artificial como una tecnología y otra
cosa son los sistemas expertos y para
que una Inteligencia artificial se
transforme en un sistema experto tiene
que ser entrenada por expertos humanos y
también supervisada porque además hay
que ir afinándolo es como un alumno que
está en primero de carrera y los
profesores universitarios pues tenemos
que enseñarle
que le interrumpa porque nos quedamos
con muy poco tiempo en relación a lo que
usted mismo dice ahora mismo la
Inteligencia artificial es entrenada
Pero qué tan Cerca o lejos estamos de lo
llamada Inteligencia artificial Total
que pueda digamos parecerse a un cerebro
humano
bueno en algunas tareas estamos cerca en
otras estamos lejísimos la Inteligencia
artificial Todavía está en pañales bueno
Borja se nos acaba Lamentablemente el
tiempo pero muchísimas gracias por
hacernos este repaso sobre el panorama
de la Inteligencia artificial que como
decíamos tanta preocupación y tanta
Esperanza su cita entre nuestras
sociedades a ustedes
y ustedes sigan con nosotros Porque
enseguida volvemos con más economía más
deportes más información aquí ya en la
última media hora de directo América
[Música]